>> ♪ ♪
>> HERE'S A SENTENCE I THOUGHT I
WOULD NEVER SAY:
PRESIDENT TRUMP POSTPONED A TRIP
TO DENMARK BECAUSE THE PRIME
MINISTER WON'T SELL HIM
GREENLAND.
I AM OKAY ABOUT IT.
IT'S A RAINY LITTLE MONARCHY
WITH 100 ISLANDS.
CANCELLING A MEETING WITH
DENMARK IS LIKE BLOWING OFF
LUNCH WITH THE 3rd COUSIN WHO
WAXES HIS MUSTACHE.
WHETHER IT'S GREENLAND, OMAR OR
SLEEPY JOE, ALL YOU ARE WATCHING
IS A SHOW.
THEY ARE COMIC SIDEKICKS.
TRUMP TURNED HIS PRESIDENCY INTO
HIS DREAM JOB.
A TALK SHOW ON WHEEL AND DOESN'T
HAVE TO SPRING FOR THE BUDGET
AND LIVES IN HIS OWN GREENROOM.
THE MEDIA FOLLOWS LIKE GROUPIE.
AND TRUMP CAN OFFER AN OPINION
THAT FUELS THE NEXT EPISODE.
IT'S GENIUS.
THEN THE TWEET FROM TRUMP.
THIS IS NOT JUST A PRESIDENCY,
IT'S THE TRUMAN SHOW REDONE AS
THE TRUMP SHOW WHICH IS GOOD
BECAUSE TRUMP IS WAY FUNNIER
THAN JIM CARREY.
THE DANGEROUS IS FOLLOWING THE
MEDIA'S LEAD AND GETTING
OBSESSED WITH THIS.
THEY REACT TO EVERY NEW PLOT
TWIST AND THAT'S NOT HEALTHY.
SIT BACK AND ENJOY THE SHOW.
IT'S FUN UNTIL SOMEBODY LOSES AN
I-LAND.
>> I SEE WHAT YOU DID THERE.
>> I THINK DENMARK IS PLAYING
HARD TO GET.
THEY WANT THE HIGHEST BID.
>> LIKE ART OF THE DEAL.
>> YES.
[LAUGHING].
>> I WOULD LIKE TO GO TO
DENMARK.
NEVER BEEN.
REMEMBER IN ALL OF THESE THINGS,
THE PRIME MINISTER HAS POLITICS
TOO AND HAS TO DEAL WITH HER
PRESS THAT IS NOT THE SAME.
THE PRESIDENT DIDN'T EXPECT THIS
TO LEAK.
IT'S A POSSIBILITY.
THEN IT LEAKS.
NOW WE ARE IN A FIGHT WITH
DENMARK?
>> THIS IS LIKE TRUMP IN THE
SENSE THAT HE ASKS QUESTIONS
THEY WOULD ASK.
DOES ANYBODY OWN THE MOON?
>> WE DO.
>> CAN I BUY EASTER ISLAND?
>> I BET I COULD.
>> EVERYTHING YOU TELL TRUMP IS
A CONSIDERATION.
HE WILL TALK ABOUT IT OPENING
AND THIS IS SOMETHING WE CAN
CONSIDER.
THEY TALK ABOUT IT AND HE
CHANGES HIS MIND.
HE WILL TALK TO ANYONE ABOUT
ANYTHING.
I AM STILL ON MANIFEST DESTINY
GREENLAND.
EVERYONE SAYS GLOBAL WARMING IS
CAUSING THINGS TO MELT.
DENMARK, PUT IT TO A VOTE.
THEY CAN DECIDE.
ON A SERIOUS NOTE, IN 10 YEARS
THE MEDIA WILL BE SAYING WHAT
ARE WE DOING ABOUT THE CHINESE
AND GREENLAND?
THEY WANT TO MINE IN GREENLAND
AND PUT A BUNCH OF AIRPORTS IN
GLEAN LAND.
-- KOREAN LAND.
-- GREENLAND.
CHINA IS ON A 100 YEAR PLAN AND
CHINA IS ALREADY THERE.
WE ARE PLAYING THE SHORT GAME
AND THEY ARE PLAYING THE LONG
GAME.
>> WHAT ARE WE GOING TO DO ABOUT
AFRICA AND BRAZIL?
>> A NEW GREEN DEAL.
>> I WAS STRUCK THE WAY HE DOES
DIPLOMACY HE CALLED HER NASTY.
>> HE CALLED A LOT OF PEOPLE
THAT.
>> I KNOW.
I THOUGHT IT WAS A JOKE!
HE CONFIRMS THE JOKE.
>> IT'S NOT A JOKE.
>> IF IT WAS JUST A PRIVATE
DISCUSSION, WHY DID HE SAY, NO,
I REALLY THINK THIS IS AN IDEA.
HERE'S THE HISTORICAL
BACKGROUND.
IT WAS ABSURD.
THEN HE SAID WHY ARE YOU CALLING
IT ABSURD?
THE PROBLEM IS WITH HIM AND NOT
WITH THE PEOPLE IN DENMARK OR
GREENLAND.
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING].
>> YOU ARE HAVING A MENTAL BREAK
DOWN.
IT'S FUN.
>> YOU THINK IT'S THE TRUMAN
SHOW.
>> YES.
>> THE TRUMAN SHOW WOULD BE LIKE
A COMEDY.
>> THIS GUY IS SUPPOSED TO BE
OUR PRESIDENT.
>> EVERY SINGLE U.S. PRESIDENT
WOULD ACQUIRE GREENLAND IF THEY
HAD THE CHANCE.
TWO PAST U.S. PRESIDENTS TRIED
TO ACQUIRE GREENLAND.
THAT'S NOT ABSURD.
HE IS OPEN TO THIS.
YOU KNOW WHO IS NASTY?
THE DANISH LEADER WAS NASTY.
ALL SHE HAD TO SAY WAS WE LOVE
GREENLAND.
I APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
ALSO HAS LOVING FEELINGS TOWARDS
THIS PART OF THE WORLD.
MAYBE WE CAN DISCUSS IT WHEN WE
HAVE THIS MEETING WHICH I EXPECT
CAN GO GREAT TO SOLIDIFY U.S.
AND DANISH RELATIONSHIPS.
SHE RUDELY DISMISSED IT AS
ABSURD.
>> I WOULD USE IT TO EXTRACT
CONCESSIONS FROM THE UNITED
STATES.
THEY ARE UNDER-BUDGET ON THEIR
NATO DUES BY A COUPLE OF BILLION
DOLLARS.
STRING TRUMP ALONG.
>> HEY, GREG.
>> THERE ARE PEOPLE IN
GREENLAND.
SHE SAID YOU CAN'T BUY PEOPLE.
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING].
>> [LAUGHING].
>> THAT'S ABSURD.
>> RUSSIA IS A HUGE THREAT BUT
THE ACQUISITION OF GREENLAND
WOULD DETER RUSSIA.
>> YOU SHOULD BE THE NEXT
AMBASSADOR TO GREENLAND OR THE
GOVERNOR OF GREENLAND.
>> YOU ARE TRYING TO GET ME OUT
OF HERE?
>> NO, THERE ARE DIPLOMAT
SOLUTIONS.
>> WE COULD CONSIDER ALL OPTIONS
AND BUY AS MANY INTERESTING
THINGS AS WE CAN.